Now, we're going to look at actual code.
We're showing this in the class IDE.
We're going to walk through it very quickly and then run it in a shell window.
And then we'll come back and look at specific bits of the code,
so you're sure you know what all of these calls do.
Then when we're done with that, we're going to ask you to make some changes and run it yourself.
So this is the actual class IDE.
I'm scrolling up and down.
Here is our main routine. That's what we're going to run.
Let me briefly go through what we're looking at
and then I'll switch over to a shell window and show you how it actually runs.
We're going to start off by running code here
that's going to generate the input array on the host.
Then we will declare the GPU memory pointers,
allocate the memory for those pointers,
copy our host array over to the device.
Here's where the magic happens.
This is where we actually launch the kernel.
We then take the results here and copy them back to the CPU
and then we print out the resulting array, free the memory, and return 0.
And if we go way back up to the top here,
here's the actual kernel that we're going to run.
Notice it's very simple.
Recall that we write a serial program here,
and we know that all that program is going to do is square its input and return it into output.
Now, let's actually run this code.
What we see here is me connected to a Cuda capable computer, actually in our lab at UC Davis.
We're going to first look at the code itself just so you know I'm compiling the real thing.
Okay, here's our program.
Now we're going to compile it, and here is the command to compile it.
You don't have to worry about this in the class IDE,
but I'm just showing you what this looks like if you're running things on your own computer.
What we see here is instead of running the regular C compiler we're running NVCC, the Nvidia C Compiler.
The output is going to go an executable called square and our input file is square.cu.
Dot cu is the convention for how we name Cuda files when we're saving them in a file system, okay?
So, it completes pretty quickly.
Then I'm going to run the program square.
What's square done?
It's taken our 64 element input array of the numbers 0 to 63,
and it squared each one of those and printed out the output.
We see 0, 1, 4, 9, 16, and so on, all the way up to 63 squared.
Now, again, you'll do this in the class IDE and some of the later examples that we do in this class
will show how you do it in the class IDE.
But just for now I'm showing you the results of this program done in a shell window.
Let's go back to our code.